Yo ! C'est Cyrus et bienvenue dans ce nouvel épisode du coup de Phil'
Enfin, vous vous en doutez.
Et comment vous vous en doutez ?
Vous n'avez pas eu besoin de vous faire une démonstration mathématique dans votre tête,
c'est juste que vous avez vu ma gueule, vous avez vu le titre de la vidéo
et vous vous êtes dit : c'est un Coup de Phil' .
Et là-dedans on est carrément, complètement, dans le cadre de l'empirisme de John Locke.
[ Musique : dj8beat - Le Coup de Phil' - Royalty-free Music Vs Hip-Hop (Jurassic 5, The D.O.C, MC Lyte) ]
John Locke c'est non seulement le personnage le plus stylé de Lost,
mais c'est aussi, et surtout, un philosophe anglais du 17è siècle.
S'il ne mangeait pas beaucoup c'est parcequ'il passait son temps à travailler sur sa théorie de la connaissance
et sa théorie politique.
Mais c'est la théorie de la connaissance qui nous intéresse ici.
Pour lui, l'origine de la connaissance nous vient de l’expérience
donc direct ça veut dire un truc : c'est que l'inné n'existe pas.
Et ça c'est une grosse problématique,
parce que si l'inné n'existe pas :
ça veut dire qu'on a pas de narines, ça veut dire que on a un trou au milieu du visage,
on n'a pas d'odorat, on ne peut pas gagner les doigts dans l'inné,
enfin ça pose quand même de grosses questions tu vois.
Tout nous vient donc de l'expérience qui pour Locke a deux sources :
la source extérieure liée aux sens
et la source intérieure, c'est la réflexion.
Et pour Locke, les sens avaient des canaux bien séparés,
et c'est pour ça que je vais vous parler du problème de Molyneux.
"" Bienvenue mesdames et messieurs dans le Cyrus Show.
Ici un compteur, lorsque ce compteur arrivera à zéro, je vous demanderai de faire pause
et de mettre en commentaire de la vidéo votre réponse au problème qui suit
qui est le problème de Molyneux
Voici la question : si un aveugle de naissance avait été opéré, et qu'il pouvait ensuite voir,
et qu'il voyait, donc pour la première fois, un cube et une sphère, qu'il avait appris au préalable à distinguer
par le toucher, est-ce qu'il pourrait les reconnaître avec pour seul sens la vue ? ""
Bref ces deux types d'expérience, qui sont les expériences extérieures avec les sens
et les expériences intérieures avec ta réflexion vont t'aider à produire des idées.
D'abord, les idées simples de sensation : par exemple la température, le mouvement, la forme.
Ensuite, les idées simples de réflexion qui viennent en fait des capacités internes :
par exemple la mémoire, la volonté, l'attention...
Et enfin il y a les idées simples qui sont à la fois de la sensation et de la réflexion :
par exemple la durée : j'ai besoin d'une expérience sensible des choses qui m'entourent
et en même temps, ça fait appel à ma faculté interne, comme la mémoire.
Les idées simples sont donc des idées que tu ne peux pas expliquer mais dont il faut faire soi-même l'expérience.
Par exemple, je ne peux pas expliquer la couleur bleue à quelqu'un qui n'a jamais vu de bleu.
"" - Ok, alors c'est une couleur, c'est la couleur du ciel, la couleur de la sérénité, la couleur royale...
- Je vois pas ! Je vois pas !
-Ok bon, alors c'est un truc quand tu le touches c'est l'inverse de rugueux,
c'est agréable, c'est...
- Je vois pas non plus, je vois pas !
Non désolé, je voyais pas... ""
Ensuite on va pouvoir faire plein de trucs avec ces idées simples.
Déjà on va pouvoir combiner les idées simples pour former des idées complexes.
Par exemple, l'idée de "tuer" plus l'idée de "homme", ça fait l'idée de "meurtre"
qui est une idée complexe.
L'idée de "tuer" plus l'idée de "homme" plus l'idée de "préméditation", ça fait l'idée d'assassinat.
Ensuite on va pouvoir mettre des idées côte à côte, qu'elles soient simples ou complexes,
dans le but de créer des idées de relation
par exemple enfant-parent.
Stéréotype : " Ça va les Ch'tis ? Bien ? Tranquille ?"
Et enfin on va pouvoir séparer une idée de toutes celles qui les entourent
et c'est comme ça qu'on va créer une idée générale.
Par exemple, tu croises un grand chien brun type berger allemand,
et ensuite, un petit chien blanc type terrier,
tu vas réussir à faire abstraction de leurs caractéristiques pour garder cette idée de chien,
cette idée générale de chien.
En gros, pour Locke, c'est cette capacité d'abstraction qu'on a qui nous permet d'avoir le langage.
"" - Mais c'est pas une PS4, c'est une bouilloire...
- Il est compliqué ! T'as vraiment un problème avec les idées générales toi, c'est fou ça !
C'est un appareil électronique, c'est la même chose. C'est dingue, il lui manque la case abstraction ou quoi ?
Tu gâches toujours tout en plus ! T'es chiant ! ""
Maintenant n'hésitez pas à vous-même tester la théorie de la connaissance de John Locke
avec d'abord une expérience extérieure qui pourrait être par exemple de vous abonner à cette chaîne,
pour ensuite avoir des expériences intérieures via les prochaines vidéos qui vont sortir.
Donc, l'expérience intérieure c'est la réflexion, vous vous souvenez ?
Vous pouvez aussi passer le Coup de Phil' à un ami si ça vous a plu,
et surtout checker la description pour avoir plus d'infos.
"" Et bien la réponse, mesdames et messieurs, c'était non !
Et c'est John Locke et les empiristes qui avaient raison, bravo ! Bravo !
Je vous envoie du love et de la peace !
J’espère que l’empirisme de John Locke est maintenant plus clair pour vous
ça s'oppose pas mal à ce qu'on avait vu dans le tout premier épisode du Coup de Phil' sur Platon
parce que Platon, pour lui, les idées, t'en a plein qui sont déjà dans ta tête,
mais en fait, c'est inné, tu fais de la réminiscence etc..
Je vous renvoie vers la vidéo si vous ne voyez pas de quoi je parle.
Cette vidéo est aussi dans la continuité de Berkeley, l'immatérialisme de Berkeley,
puisque Berkeley, c'est un empiriste aussi, et donc il y a certaines idées,
qu'on retrouve vaguement chez Locke, même si Locke est beaucoup, beaucoup, beaucoup moins taré.